what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we got hit up a lot on
social media about the flash Big Game
Spot I thought it would just be shorter
version of the official trailer but
apparently there's some new footage in
here now we're gonna have to check this
out go a little bit frame by frame
please check out our reaction to the
official trailer that's up here on the
channel hi koi I am excited hi John hi
I'm excited ladies and gentlemen leave a
like let's see what's going on
[Music]
cool
what's happening
whoa [__] changed the future
I want some help
you're you are you're yeah
I'm Batman Beyond
the supervision
dude that trailer what did they just do
to us oh he's gonna get the flash ring
oh man that was so cool wasn't the big
trailer that was in the picture I
totally missed it oh yeah that's why
we're framed by Framing there you go
there's a lot happening
holy crap throw a little bit Friend by
frame you guys tell me if you want me to
just stop at anything right here I mean
the suit Up's great okay so some people
were saying immediately that this was uh
Christian Bale's Bat Bike uh the Bat
Bike in that movie doesn't have the the
two front wheels like this that is
definitely bat Flex that's 100
years there were set photos too that
showed that bethleck was on a a bike I
think people just want the bail so is
this I can't tell if this is a splice of
like the early in the movie
or something like this is World engine
from Man of Steel moment yeah and then
this I feel like is the beginning of the
movie where the whatever that big action
scene is that I imagine the film's gonna
start off with where you see that Barry
Allen is working with bat flick I don't
I don't feel like this is I don't think
that's related I agree with you yeah I
think this is just some clever match
yeah and this must be like I don't know
when this is towards the end of the
movie or something like that this shot
yeah I mean the Zod Supergirl shot is so
cool that is epic where is this it looks
like they're in the middle of the desert
this time yeah versus the city someplace
abandoned where they don't hey look we
don't have cases
like 15 years of notes they're decided
yeah because this whole thing with the
armies it looks like it's all taking
place in like a desert versus in the
middle of metropolis I mean it's like if
you have a villain that's wreaking havoc
if you take them out of the city it
might be a better way to be a hero true
so some might do that what are you
talking about I don't know it's an idea
and actually slowing this down really
does look like like I don't know if this
is they're both getting Powers here or
he's trying to get powers that's so
intense that's like that's so metal I
love this shot cover him jumping out of
the it's very Iron Man like yeah and
Captain America Winter Soldier where he
like exactly oh that's so cool that's a
great shot
we got this look at these like visuals
man I know it's in the original trailer
but still also you can see the reverse
here where that there isn't the world
breaker thing and also yeah there's also
two wheels here versus with um versus
the big tumbler gas I'm like but I was
just saying for your theory of this
isn't that scene for sure because it'd
be in that shot yeah well yeah and and I
thought of back to what you said during
the original trailer reaction where like
yeah it's like the Multiverse of
directors because I think people could
get confused because these bat Flex
sequences on the bike do look like they
are inspired by the visual language of
The Dark Knight you know and that's you
know the biggest Touchstone on screen
for that vehicle I love this speed force
moment is that a film reel yeah it looks
like it
it's it's the Lost uh Snyder cut
okay who's this I have no idea who this
is gray hair long it's Berry in the
future
as of his time oh Alfred he's let
himself Go I mean this looks like it's
part of Wayne Manor could be it could be
but who has who has gray hair and long
gray I mean maybe we meet a different
Bruce because we're about to see a lot
of Bruce's name Keaton cuts his hair
first yeah he's growing it up first he
has long hair and then he cuts it yeah
he's talking to this kid
yeah I love this shot
look at this
yeah and we've got a bit of a bad armor
on the on the second from the right yeah
yeah I like the different cowl
attachments and they all look in a
different degree of like wornness like
that one in the back looks especially
dirty over his green left shoulder oh
yeah oh yeah I love the goggle the
variations of the device and stuff yeah
and the different like ways they for uh
the like eyebrows yeah this film looks
beautiful I am so excited these shots
look very IMAX heavy yeah it gets me I'm
excited for uh for Andy muschietti too
because he's the director he's held a
lot of big stuff but I'm still waiting
for like what is his stamp of you know
tone and visual you know we didn't go
frame by frame with the full trailer but
they expanded on this from the original
teaser trailer yeah showing that it is
the Batmobile him freaking out the
bullets to the syncopation the music was
so dope like that was clever okay so
there's your ring that's cool what is
the ring like how did he make the ring
because there's a tad bit of yellow here
yeah so it makes me think it's a 2013
berry oh interesting I mean and is the
villain just gonna be yellow what 2012
one was Man of Steel 2012 or 2013 2012.
yeah but also are we getting uh you know
yellow flash I don't think that's this
shot but like is the evil Flash gonna be
a part of this or is it gonna be like
yeah in the universe where he still has
his mom he doesn't have powers then
flash gives him his powers but then that
causes him to turn into yellow flash
that's a good point too can we can we
acknowledge that he kind of has a blue
Cape here with gray yes this is a bit
Neil Adams and that is my jam I love me
a blue suit this is definitely the
continuation of him coming out of the
plane oh that is so freaking cool that's
gonna be a great secret it's gonna be so
giving him like a good final sequence
yeah
I don't know what he's freaking out over
here he's just uh he's responding to the
charger it might be when his mom is
getting murdered trying to be watching
the old murder yeah uh okay there's a
lot of dude like this is all army with
these these lightning bolts which is
interesting well this looks like it's
the two flashes yeah no no I was just
looking at what they're attacking like
I'm wondering if this is like they're
losing the fight and everything comes
down to them kind of thing uh well
that's the two of them in the middle and
then they're just gonna like shoot off
to one side I think either trying to
save the people oh they're trying to
save the soldiers
these are yeah like are these
kryptonians are these ours I thought
only show up with a small handful of
people but he's got like ships and yeah
these are these look alien these ships
yeah the ships I'm saying they're
fighting with them yeah but these look
like they're regular
I can't see that's what I can't tell
yeah I thought troops or if those are
Zod troops or it could be them fighting
yeah either way it's interesting I like
the Starship Trooper
my favorite shot is now this blue and
gray suit like I'm just overwhelmed by
Ben Affleck and blue and right that's so
exciting that's a cool TV spot I'm
excited for this movie man I think it's
gonna be cool it's gonna be red it's
James Gunn's favorite movie all right
guys well you excited for the flash of
your thoughts down below be sure to
subscribe totally missed the ring in the
last video I just I'm so impressed that
it looks as good as we've heard because
it we heard the sky was gonna Park
yep all right guys so leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
follow koi on the socials last but not
least
Aaron Myers Buddy Aaron my dude
we have a bunch of shout out ideas for
you but you know what we're gonna do
we're gonna start for the traditional
one we looked up in the meaning of your
name it means exalted or strong it's
been interpreted to mean teacher or
mountain of strength that is so cool I
like to imagine that you are a skinny
scrawny little guy with like four
different sets of glasses and you're
constantly having your head down and you
have a hoodie yard gear shaggy hair a
bunch of inhalers you're always using
the last thing you want is any sort of
conflict and someone shoves you into the
locker room and you're always covered in
a body cast my name's Aaron I have a
mountain I am fragile do not break me
um yeah you know he did a completely
opposite thing of what what I said there
but we were on the same page for so long
you know yeah
I'm sorry Aaron I was just intimidated
by your strength as the mountain of
strength that you are just kidding we
know that you're probably a very very
handsome individual with um and you I'm
sure you put on this display here every
Aaron I've ever got to know is a great
guy and exclusively I think they are an
exalted individual that's what I always
say that's that's a common compliment
that I give around town you are exalted
sir you're an exotic person you are
exalted this Eve so and you are
especially exalted thank you Aaron for
being here for being part of our patreon
page for bumping up here obviously we
don't really know what you look like so
I'd please don't take anything
but uh thank you for thank you for
showing your support man it means a lot
to have you as a super sexy reject here
at the reject Nation